le tourisme les professionnels cherchent
en permanence à séduire les clients les
thèmes sont de plus en plus variés
thermalisme vendanges aux sports vtt
château culture et pourquoi pas le
tourisme religieux
reportage à lisieux sur les traces de
sainte thérèse à la nourrice qui kodan
paradoxe chaque dimanche les paroissiens
se font de plus en plus rare dans les
églises de france
mais chaque jour les touristes eux se
font plus nombreux exemples ici à
lisieux où l'an dernier 6 millions de
personnes ont suivi les traces de
sainte-thérèse motivations religieuses
parfois mais surtout recherche de
racines culturelles
c'est un voyage véritablement culturel
mais comme on voit des choses
extraordinaires probablement on a aussi
touché
du côté spirituel tous contents de se
retrouver mais a pas eu de problèmes
entre nous et non personne tout en
sachant très grave et qu'il n'avait pas
la foire chez nous c'est en s'adaptant
ce genre de clientèle celle qui n'a pas
la foi que les voyagistes ont réussi à
développer le tourisme religieux
d'ailleurs sur place à lisieux au plus
haut niveau on est conscient de cette
réalité économique
je ne cherche pas à vendre ma
marchandise je voudrais quand même être
un témoin que ce qui hélas a une
histoire pour nous dans ces lieux où on
accueille les touristes
il faut que nous nous adaptions et il me
semble qu'il faut que nous soyons très
créatif
les touristes sont désormais pris en
main visite de la maison de
sainte-thérèse du carmel où elle s'est
retirée
l'idée générale est de créer un
véritable circuit pour des visiteurs
venus parfois de très loin des états
unis viennent d'argentine viennent
d'espagne d'australie
là c'est un coup de philippins du monde
entier viennent pour lisieux les
retombées financières sont presque
miraculeuse on les estime à 100 millions
d'euros par an en profitent également
les activités profane appel
recueillement une halte à la distillerie
par exemple
l'automne c'est la saison idéale pour
les fossés joie